[Musique]
c'est beau les français oui de
belleville
mais c'est miami vous allez adorer
j'arrive pas à le croire car on est amer
avec toi à néry bah oui avec moi je n'ai
pas réussi
une fois que j'ai résolu la sphère
orange 2012 profite je suis dit profites
t'elle préqualifiante mellac moi je veux
pas d'un lassus ta mère ouais toi on est
amer avec toi sa voiture pas t'y mets
toi aussi tu es moi je suis né avec
cebu le français lui de belleville
non mais c'est miami
vous allez adorer
donc il faut parler anglais mieux ça je
parle le flic américain am tour le
protégé de ihs global donnant fatal
shadows et l'octroi de plein fouet jam
access to it like près yes merci de
flint de blind side of life province
plus c'est ce que j'avais dit
vous connaissez miami vous allez adorer
tombe dix jours il retrouve mon boulot
pépère j'ai fait pas des problèmes qu
espérer que le reste de la police
française mais pas quand vous
ici à la mairie poursuit ce déplacement
les règlements ça va pas de plaire à
bien avec le règlement on n'est pas
forcé d'être toujours eu deux dents au
caire 6 1